Now let's discuss the solution to our two bit
predictor quiz. We have a two bit predictor like
this. The question is, is there a sequence of
branch outcomes, such that this predictor, starting in the
strong note taken state always mispredicts. And the answer
is of course yes. Every single predictor has the
worst case scenario of always mispredicting. What you have
to do to find out what that worst-case scenario
is, is simply design a sequence such that whatever
the state of the predictor is, the sequence goes
the opposite way. So, we start in the strong
not taken state, thus the first decision will be taken,
and that will take us to a weak not
taken state. The predictor will still predict not taken,
so we make the branch be taken next time.
Now the predictor goes to the weak taken state and
now we know how to cause the alternation between the
states. So in the weak taken state, we go not taken.
It moves to weak not taken, now we say taken and
so on. So you can just keep doing this. So pretty
much, even if we do start in a strong taken
state, there is a way to move us to a weak
state, at which point we can do this alternation. Note that
for this particular sequence, there is a way to change this
predictor so that this behavior doesn't result in
100% misprediction. But in general, every predictor no
matter how it's organized, will always have some
sequence as it's worst possible outcome. It's just
a matter of how likely is that sequence.
A good predictor will not have this worst
case behavior for some thing that is a
very likely sequence to happen. So again, every predictor
has a worst-case scenario where it's doing 100% mispredictions.